[Music]
hi my name is Sally I'm a software
engineer at Google and I work on the
storage stack of kubernetes today I'm
going to talk about storage classes and
dynamic volume provisioning a new
feature in kubernetes first I'll
introduce these concepts and then my
colleague Matt will walk you through a
demo on gke let's start by identifying
what problems kubernetes volume plugins
are aiming to solve first is that the
basic unit of scheduling and kubernetes
is a pod which is a collection of
containers containers do not share their
file system but pods are composed of
possibly multiple containers this could
be for example a reader and a writer
container that work together so it would
be really nice to be able to share files
between containers in a pod second
problem is that containers are ephemeral
and the files inside a container are
also ephemeral meaning they're deleted
when the container is terminated this
means if a container crashes or the
machine is restarted you lose your data
inside the container if you're trying to
run a stateful service having your data
disappear as a non-starter this is where
kubernetes volumes come in at its core
of volume is just a directory possibly
with some data pre-populated in it which
is accessible to all the containers in a
pod how that directory comes to be the
medium that backs it its content what
happens to it after the pod is
terminated are all determined by the
particular volume type used ok let's
take a look at the volume plugins we
have in kubernetes the plugins can be
categorized into a few large buckets one
class of volumes is persistent network
attached storage these are volumes that
outlive the life cycle of a pod this
could be anything from NFS share to a
cloud provider virtual disk the life
cycle of these volumes is independent
from the lifecycle of an individual pod
when a pod referencing one of these
volumes is created the storage is
automatically made available inside the
container of that pod the volumes are
automatically attached and mounted when
the pod is terminated the volume is
automatically unmounted and detached if
needed but the data on the volume
remains intact and that's the key the
data is persisted if another pod comes
along and references the same instance
of the volume they'll see the same exact
data another class of volumes is
ephemeral these volumes are created when
a pod starts and is deleted when a pod
is terminated empty der is the prime
example here it is shared scratch space
between pods kubernetes creates an empty
directory on the underlying node machine
either from the local disk or from an
in-memory temp FS and it mounts the
directory into all the containers in the
pod then when the containers start they
have some shared scratch space between
them when the pod is terminated the
directory and its content is deleted
secret config map and downward API or
concepts in the kubernetes api there are
mechanisms for sharing configuration and
cluster information with applications
one of the core principles of kubernetes
is to meet the users where they are this
means that instead of requiring
applications to talk the kubernetes api
we try to make the data available in the
form applications already know how to
consume so while existing apps won't
necessarily know how to talk the
kubernetes api
they can probably already read config
info from a file and so secret config
map and downward api volumes are a
mechanism for exposing these kubernetes
api objects as files inside the
container of a pod these volumes are
essentially an empty dirt under the
cover but pre-populated with the
contents of the kubernetes api server on
creation instead of being empty now
let's take a look at an example here we
have a pod a pod is a basic unit of
scheduling in kubernetes pods are a
collection of containers or in this case
a single busybox container that doesn't
really do anything but sleep on startup
this pod directly references a Google
compute engine persistent disk volume
called panda disk for use by all the
containers in this pod the volume is
assumed to already exist the pod also
defines where inside the container the
volume should be mounted now this
example seems pretty trivial but the
real beauty is what happens under the
covers when the pot is created
kubernetes automatically calls
to the Google cloud API and attaches the
specified PD to the node that the pod is
scheduled to it then formats the disk if
needed and mounts it into the container
that makes up the pod when the pot is
moved to another node kubernetes
automatically calls out to the google
cloud api detaches the persistent disk
from the first node and attaches it to
the second node and repeats the same
song-and-dance to mount the volume
inside the new instance of the pod on
the second node all of this happens
invisibly for the user and makes it so
that they don't have to worry about what
machine the workload actually landed on
kubernetes just takes care of it but
there's something not quite right here
let's take a step back and talk about a
really nice design principle that many
of you are probably familiar with the
separation of concerns it says that the
components managing distinct
functionality should themselves be
separated this enables you to isolate
revise and test components independently
it allows you to make your larger system
modular so that you can swap out pieces
without affecting other components and
kubernetes does exactly that it takes
functionality that used to be smeared
across various layers and handles them
explicitly it decouples the application
layer from the cluster resources
required to run applications that means
as an application developer you don't
have to worry about the implementation
details of the cluster your workload is
running on anymore you don't have to
worry about which particular machine
your app is running on you don't have to
worry about whether that machine has
enough ports you don't have to worry
about what other apps are running on
that machine kubernetes abstracts all of
that away and exposes an api that allows
you as an application developer to
simply describe the service you want to
run along with the resources it will
require kubernetes takes care of the
rest if you think about it kubernetes in
this regard is very much like an
operating system for clusters think back
to the earliest days of computers when
there were no operating systems and
every program needed a full hardware
spec to perform even the basic tasks
distributed system application
development has been in this stage for a
long time and now kubernetes finally
introduces an abstract
layer that hides the implementation
details and complexity of cluster
implementation the real beauty of an
abstraction layer is that it allows you
to swap out the components underneath it
it enables portability you can run
kubernetes in a lot of different
environments
everything from cloud providers like
Google cloud AWS and even on bare metal
on Prem clusters all with a consistent
API this be coupling of application from
cluster allows applications to be cloud
provider agnostic and not worry about
network model load balancing persistent
storage this is great for you as an
application developer because it allows
you to write your applications services
deployment descriptions once and have
them work regardless of the underlying
cluster it helps avoid vendor lock-in
now that's a really pretty picture I
just painted but for those of you who
are paying attention you probably are
asking didn't your pod definition
specify exactly the type of volume to
use for persistent storage you specified
a GC EPD with the name panda disk now if
you take that pod description and drop
it on a non GCE cluster it's not going
to work right you would be absolutely
right this is where the kubernetes
concepts of persistent volume and
persistent volume claim objects comes
into the picture
persistence volume and persistent volume
claim objects enable an abstraction
between the consumption of storage and
the implementation of storage the
persistent volume object is a
representation of a piece of storage
available on the cluster and the
persistent volume claim is a request for
storage on behalf of an application
trying to run on the cluster let's take
a look at an example first we have to
expose the storage available for the
application to use we do this by
creating a PV object to represent each
piece of storage available for
applications to use on the cluster
each persistent volume object contains a
description of the storage it exposes
and connection information normally
cluster or storage administrators create
these PV objects not application
developers once these PV objects are
created they're available for use now if
an application developer wants to use
storage on this cluster they must first
request for storage this is done by
creating a PVC object in the PVC object
you define the minimum requirements for
the storage you need the minimum disk
capacity in the required access modes
when the PVC object is created
kubernetes takes the request and matches
it with an available unbound TV in this
case it finds one of the PV objects that
we created earlier a 100 gigabyte gcep D
is available and unbound so it binds
this to the request the PVC now this
claim can be used by the application
developer let's go back to the pod
definition we used earlier in order to
use the storage you can now reference
the claim for storage instead of
directly referencing a specific volume
the beauty of this is that our pod
definition is now portable the request
for storage resources is decoupled from
the specific implementation of storage
we can take this pod definition and drop
it on any kubernetes cluster and as long
as there is available storage it will
just work and even if you're running
only on a single cluster it means that
your cluster administrator can
completely swap out or modify the
storage system in your cluster but your
pod definitions won't need to change so
the persistent volume and persistent
volume claim abstraction is really nice
for giving us portability but you
probably noticed that there was a step
in there that was a little cumbersome
having a cluster admin or storage
provider pre provision all the volumes
available for use in the cluster this is
where dynamic volume provisioning comes
in this is a feature that is unique to
kubernetes the idea is that when a
request for storage is created when a PV
C is created the cluster automatically
creates a new piece of storage to
fulfill that request this makes a lot of
sense in cloud environments like gke
where an API call can provision new
storage within a matter of seconds but
even for non cloud storage systems like
NFS you could write a provision air that
maybe triggers the creation of a new
share on demand to use dynamic
provisioning the cluster storage admin
must first enable it they do this by
creating one or more storage class
objects the storage class objects
specified
the volume plug-in to use for
provisioning and the parameters to pass
to that plug-in the parameters for the
storage class are a blob of key value
pairs that the provisioner presumably
understands in this case the first
storage class says when executed called
the GCE PD volume plug-in and pass in
parameters to create a standard spinning
disk the second storage class pretty
much says the same thing but instead
passes in parameters to create an SSD
GCE PD the parameters are defined by the
volume plug-in and set by cluster admins
and are opaque to kubernetes otherwise
what's really neat about that is that
since the parameter list is a blob that
is passed through to the provisioner
kubernetes doesn't have to get into the
business of enumerated
for every storage system in its API
plugins expose an arbitrary set of knobs
for disk provisioning and cluster admins
can tweak them at will
cluster admins can define multiple
storage classes to expose different
tiers or groupings of storage to cluster
users and users don't have to worry
about the details so in this case the
cluster admin exposed what they called
Fast and Slow storage and application
developers don't have to worry about the
details of what that means under the
covers they just pick from the storage
classes that are exposed to them to use
storage just as before the application
developer creates a persistent volume
claim object to request storage in the
persistent volume claim object they now
specify the storage class to use in
kubernetes 1.6 this is a new field in
the PVC object in earlier versions this
was an annotation on the PVC object when
a PVC object where the storage class is
created instead of binding to an
existing available pv kubernetes calls
the provisioner defined in the specified
storage class to create a new volume in
this case it calls the GCE PD plugin
which calls that to the GCE API to
create a new SSD back GCE PD once the
new storage volume is provisioned
kubernetes automatically creates a PV
object to represent
the new storage and then binds it to the
users persistent volume claim it's
important to note that dynamically
provisioned volumes are created with a
delete retention policy that means once
the PVC is deleted the dynamically
provisioned volume will automatically be
deleted if you don't want that to happen
you should update the persistent volume
object after it is automatically created
and changed the retention policy to
retain instead of delete once the new
volume is created and bound to the PVC
users can reference the PVC in their pod
definitions exactly the same way
something else to keep in mind is that
storage classes can be marked as default
marking a storage class as default makes
it so that even a PVC without a storage
class specified will trigger
provisioning instead of binding to an
existing pool of TVs this is a mechanism
for cluster admins to force dynamic
provisioning also important to note is
that kubernetes 1.6 will come with the
storage class pre-installed and set as
default for gke and other cloud
providers this is something to pay
attention to if you've been using
kubernetes for a while because it
changes the default behavior of PVC
objects on these clouds it used to be
that PVC objects without storage classes
would bind to available existing PV
objects but on these clouds with 1.6
because there will be pre-installed
default storage class a PVC without a
storage class will still trigger the
creation of a new volume if you want to
disable this behavior you'll have to
modify the storage class and remove the
default annotation now I'm going to hand
it over to Matt to demo this Thank You
Sud my name is matthew DeLeo I'm a
product manager for kubernetes and gke
and I work on networking and storage
today I'm going to be doing a couple
demos for you the first is a demo of how
to manually provision and use a disk
inside gke and the second we'll use the
dynamic provisioning feature that saw it
talked about earlier so let's jump right
in I've already created a cluster it has
three nodes in it and each one of them
has one virtual CPU I'm using version
1.5 3 of Caretti so it's going to use
the annotation that Todd mentioned
earlier
rather than the built-in storage class
things did we introduced in 1.6 so going
back to my terminal screen I'm going to
run this demo and just to see that
there's no other discs inside gke i'm
going to run this g-cloud command and
from here we can see that there's just
three disks these correspond to the
three nodes that I have in my cluster
and now we're going to check to make
sure there's no physical volumes PVS
and there's also no PVCs physical volume
claims next I will use g-cloud to create
a new disk inside google cloud platform
and I will call it manual disk one at
step number one next we're going to make
sure it exists so we're going to run the
g-cloud command to list the disks that
we have we can see that we have our
three node disks and now we also have
manual disk one next we're going to add
a corresponding physical volume to
kubernetes so I've just created a simple
yamo file that lists the name of the
actual disk that I want to use that's
the PD name down at the bottom here and
that says manual disk one then I can
give it a name I'm going to call it
manually created PV I have a capacity
that's set to 10 gigabytes and I've set
the reclaim policy to be retained so I'm
going to load that into kubernetes so
that's in now and now we're going to
make sure it exists so I'm running the
cube cuttle get PV and that will list
the disk that we have and we can see
that it exists we have 10 gigabytes
available the retain policy is what we
clinton we expectedly which is retained
and it's four seconds old now we're
going to go ahead and create a physical
volume claim by asking for 10 gigabytes
of storage we're going to call it my PVC
and we're going to go ahead now and load
that into kubernetes so at this point we
should have a PV and we should have a
PVC and the PV should be bound to the
PVC so we're going to check that real
quick and I've listed both the TV's the
physical volumes and the PVC the
physical volume claims now in the first
couple lines you see that we have a
bound PV it's bound to
has a claim of demos /my PVC and the
second last two lines we have my PVC and
it's bound to manually created PV the
final step is to use this physical
volume claim in a pod and so here we are
we've referenced the claim name that's
in this line under volumes and we're
going to head in creating a new pod it's
called Sleepypod it doesn't do much it
just sleeps for 100 minutes and then
goes to sleep so we're going to head and
created that it's going to take a few
seconds to warm up and actually create
the pod and so while we're waiting we'll
just going to check on it looks like
it's running now so I'm going to go
ahead and show you what happens when you
want to tear down one of these setups so
the first thing you need to do is delete
the pod at this point you still have a
PVC in a PV and those are still bound to
each other
and while we're waiting for that pod to
delete it takes a few seconds for the
pod to delete but once it's done we
should be able to see at this point our
pod is deleted now we're going to go
ahead and delete the PVC and also delete
the PV so as you can see I just checked
to make sure there's no PV and PVC
resources and now we need to actually
delete the disk in Google cloud platform
so I ran the g-cloud command to do that
so that's it there's four steps of
manually provisioning a physical volume
and using it in kubernetes the first
step is to go ahead and create the
volume in Google Cloud the second step
is to create a PV object in kubernetes
then you need to create a PVC object
physical volume claim in kubernetes and
then you can finally use it in a pod
next I'll show how we can use dynamic
volume provisioning to make this process
a lot easier and so I'm going to go
ahead and start with my demo and here
just to show again that there's nothing
going on behind the scenes I've got a
list of all my disks we have again three
nodes three disks corresponding to those
three nodes and no other disks available
in the system next I'm going to go ahead
and show that there's no storage classes
we've already loaded into the system as
you can see there is none and finally
we're going to make sure that there's no
physical volumes or physical volume
claims that exist in kubernetes so we
have a pretty vanilla system right here
we haven't done anything yet the first
step is to add storage classes and so
I've got here is a yamo file it's very
simple because I'm using 1.5.2 which
still is in beta but when he goes to 1.6
this will no longer be a beta API object
I'm going to create this sword class
it's type name is fast its type is SSD
and we're going to use the GCE PD
provisioner which you can see is all
listed here in the yamo file so we'll go
ahead and load that in the kubernetes
next we're going to go ahead and list
the storage classes so you can see that
we have the fast type of storage and we
can see that it's the gcpd type now we
just have to add a PVC so this one's a
little bit different than what we had
when we were manually provisioning our
storage this one has an annotation again
the annotation will be different when we
switch to 1.6 but right now we're on 1.5
and I just have to add the annotation to
say I want the storage class set to fast
and I say that I want 10 gigabytes and
once I create this PVC what it's going
to do it's going to go ahead and
provision the storage on Google Cloud
platform and it's going to create a bind
to that storage object so to see that we
can go ahead and list the disks and you
can see that we have a new disk here
it's at the very top of the list it's a
10 gigabyte and its type is SSD just as
we expected when we created the storage
class it's very simple to now use the
PVC and the pod yamo file this is
actually the exact same yamo file used
earlier in the manually provisioned
example so let's go ahead and load that
into kubernetes
at this point the disk has already been
created and we just need to start up the
pod
great so now it's running we'll go ahead
and just show the deletion path so now I
want to delete the pod again I just
delete the pod as before it'll take some
time for the pod to actually shut down
and terminate
now the pot is shut down I'm going to go
ahead and run a g-cloud compute disks
list and this will show us all the disks
that we still have in our system as you
can see from here we still have a PVC
backed storage that would dynamically
provisioned and its size is still 10 gig
as we'd expect I'm going to go ahead and
delete the PVC when I do that I would
expect the pvat backi actual backing
disc to be deleted if we go ahead and
check that now we can see that it's
actually deleted so there you have it to
use dynamic volume provisioning all you
have to do is create a storage class
create a volume claim and then use the
volume claim and so as you can see
dynamic storage provisionally makes it a
lot easier we only had the allocate a
storage class type and we can use it
everywhere that's it for the demo thank
you very much and I'll turn it back to
sod now thank you Matt for that demo so
that's an overview of dynamic
provisioning and storage classes in gke
a unique feature in kubernetes that
enables storage to be created
automatically when it's needed thank you
for joining us to get involved or to
learn more visit us at the storage cig
to try container engine use this code
for a free trial account
you